foreign
trout
come here
[Music]
how are you oh
yes oh don't make a pass on me
giving me those little googly eyes
who is that hi
Korea hi Susie hi trout you know Priya
you know Bria look at her
is this why I can't get a hold of you
sometimes
busted
I was just going to check up on
each yes I'm headed down I
know
come move time it has to be Flawless we
have 10 sea lions down in Florida a
temporary facility while we're building
a brand new habitat that's going to be
amazing
a boy
we're very excited because we're getting
ready to bring the sea lions home to
Columbus Zoo
I love all the sea lions but there is
one that really tugs at my heart and
that is Bodega
but it's 24 years old so he's an old man
and he has been through a lot and you
know to bring him home means more to me
than anything it's exciting we're gonna
do this is the sea lion dance oh
my God
that's awesome okay yep safe travels bye
the vet team has been phenomenal they
are so excited about these animals
coming and working with this team it's
going to be a great partnership and I'm
ready to get this show on the road I
want to bring him home did you just poop
trap
poop
[Music]
all right guys
Chow Time
nope that's not yours buddy
chow time for the iguanas
bosses are a spiny tailed iguana he's
our big male he's around 17 years old
he's definitely an older man but he's
he's such a chill animal I mean he just
he happy-go-lucky that you know doesn't
have a care in the world
you don't find a fine iguanas that are
nice and as loving as bosses he's just a
big sweetheart and he's become one of
our favorites in in our reptile
Department
want some more most people don't see
reptiles as the cute and cuddly and
they're not the furry lovable types but
iguanas in general they're like dogs and
cats I mean they each have their own
individual personality it's like having
a dog at home that that you know you've
raised through through thick and thin
you know you you develop a bond with
them I have had a passion for reptiles
since I could walk my earliest memory
and and my parents never let me forget
this we went camping I was seven and
while my parents were setting up the
tent I wandered off and they lost sight
of me came and found me and I was
playing with a copperhead
you ate all the good stuff you gotta eat
some greens
a couple months ago we noticed that he
he was starting to look a little skinny
so he increased him to a daily feeder we
give him a little salad with some treats
every day then I weighed him uh last
week and he lost more weight
and you know he eats well he he's
behaving fine but he you know he's
dropping weight and he you know his hips
are starting to show
you can see that and he's like really
sunken in in the rear of his abdomen in
here that means he's losing a little bit
of his muscle that's where it becomes
super or really concerning
so we're gonna take him up and and get a
full workup done on him
I'm I'm pretty worried about him
I mean in my experience when you have an
older animal who is losing weight while
eating more it is typically not a great
outcome boss will get you up man we'll
get you up to Animal Health and and I'm
sure we'll
be able to figure out what the heck's
going on we'll leave this salad for the
rest of the day so he can come and pick
at it as he wants I think he's full with
the moment he's going to go off and mess
with some of the ladies oh no he's gonna
flirt with people outside
he's had Bob and the guests outside
so like this is normal behavior this is
this is fine
[Music]
I am down in Florida and that is where
the Columbus Zoo's Tennessee lions are
okay
we're at a temporary facility while our
incredible habitat is being built ready
to go to Columbus yeah me too
we're getting these animals ready to
transport homes
[Music]
this is the crew that is living down
there right now training these animals
daily and we'll be bringing them home
I'd like to see where we're at because
we're pretty close yeah
let's get born so
um Pablo jewelry and I'm the director of
the penny pet Department in the Columbus
Zoo oh hi big boy good boy you're a big
boy
Pablo he looks great yes he is Pablo has
many many years of experience with
pinnipeds and after meeting him I knew
he was the guy to lead the team there
was one little glitch
he was from France
so you remember Toby
it was not he was a little bit
aggressive you will see him now he
really put his fate into my hands and we
worked together and got him here which
is fantastic do you want red wine mole
America America and France what our
French French flag we look
foreign
[Music]
water
good
will she go in there at all she thought
she started to go in the crate that's
like
we did a lot of crate training with the
animal because we want them to be really
comfortable during the train spot so we
want them to be used to stay in a crate
yeah great
good
so when we ask a young female to follow
us in a crate she will follow us in a
crate because she knows that it will be
positive it will be fun it will be a lot
of fish she will receive kisses what do
you think I'm amazed you guys have done
you've done an amazing job great great
good
so the cue for the crates is that
because we want to go home and Columbus
is in our hearts
hi YouTube
means the world to me you can tell age
got a lot of gray in them and he's 24
years old he's our gentle giant Bodega
has been from facility to facility to
facility so it's kind of been my mission
to bring Bodega home you teddy bear
in the past year Bodega has overcome a
lot
he was blind We performed cataract
surgery on him so now he can see then
after that he became paralyzed in his
back flippers and threw a lot of work
with the team he now has feeling back in
his back flippers
he's the general giant here and I want
him to oh thank you
getting a sea lion kiss is very special
well he was really getting in the hair
suits new hairstyle but getting one from
Bodega is really special
it just brings me so much joy to see how
well everybody is doing hey guys I am
blown away I think we could go today
we're ready
you guys have done an amazing job
there's no doubt my mind transport will
be a breeze next time I'm down there we
are loading up and we are coming home
[Music]
good
oh my gosh
anyone want some oats right it's a
perfect dolor sized container yeah they
do work really well
Munster is one of our pygmy slow lorises
he's our breeding male so monsters had a
really long history of dental disease
and abscesses on his face he did have an
extraction procedure recently and it's
now been a week post procedure and his
face has gotten worse instead of better
so today we've decided we're going to
take monster up to the hospital to do a
CT scan on him hopefully this will give
us some answers to the issues that we've
been observing in his day-to-day
oh I didn't like that no he did not hi
monster
oh lorises are nocturnal with those huge
eyes so that they can let in as much
light as possible one thing that
everybody falls in love with are their
huge eyes
they just have that idyllic really cute
face that when you think of cute
basically everybody in their mind
pictures a Laura's face you just don't
know what it is until you actually see
it he's got this like it almost looks
like a pimple on his nose
that's all it is a pimple well
if I get to squeeze two episodes in one
day it's gonna be a really good day
you already get to squeeze one camel oh
this abscess is bigger than your whole
patient yeah
don't get it on me
poor little face he just doesn't look
comfortable his face is swollen I don't
think he can see very well his eyes kind
of partially shut we really want to help
him feel better we want to help him be a
normal Loris and we haven't been able to
figure out how to do that quite yet
let's give him some gas to relax in more
and then we'll get a CT
the whole Bridge of his nose is really
hard okay so my concern Katrina is that
he shouldn't be swollen up her Miss
dental procedure that there's something
else going on in there yeah I'm hoping
it's just a sinus infection
move to CT
I feel like he's kind of been through a
lot
and keep bringing him back and trying to
keep figuring it out and he just can't
figure it out so it's frustrating
this is tiny little head oh my gosh you
need one of those Mouse CTS
tiny
you can see the left side is completely
solid it's completely full of material
that's Emerald you can see already here
the Moon is different
and there it's completely eroded away
the other possibility looking at the CT
the amount of erosion in the bone is
that it could be bone cancer in that
area and that's what's causing all the
infection buddy let's warm you up huh
let's get you warm that's heartbreaking
when you can't figure out how to make
them normal make them feel good he
really does have just such a sweet
personality and such a good dad and
really does everything he's supposed to
do Katrina that left side is completely
occluded there's no air getting through
the end of bone it's very abnormal it
looks lytic like it's infected the other
possibility is just let it cause it's a
tumor right
he's ready to move to CT
so we have monster in CT and my initial
impression is it could be bone cancer
you can see already here the bone is
different
and there it's completely eroded away
Katrina that left side is completely
occluded there's no air getting through
the end of bone is very abnormal it
looks slidic like it's infected the
other possibility is just let it cause
it's a tumor right okay
so we're gonna start on my antibiotics
these are going to be injectable
start with that we'll get a great deal
just look at this and see if he thinks
it's uh infection or what it is we're
waiting for a radiologist to interpret
the CT to get a better handle on exactly
what we're dealing with and until then
we're doing some injectable antibiotics
with monster these are antibiotics we
haven't used before so we're hoping they
have a different effect on this
infection
well he's waking up when he sticks
it out stop poking me oh man
a little baby yeah this is how I hold
them when they wake up options every
single animal that we take care of I'm
gonna start crying
that's a special place for Arts
and he's been around for a while
it's just an awesome animal
[Music]
there you are hello
I didn't really expect this
he's such a cool animal and he has been
he's been one of the animals I've worked
really closely with since I've been in
the department so
he is really special we're gonna fix him
we'll figure it out
Mr Man let me see you
want to go back in your tube
cutest butt in the zoo
there you are good morning hey buddy
your nose feel funny
I kind of have mixed feelings about what
we found I mean I'm glad we found
something I'm hoping that once we get
this more information back that will
have a good plan going forward and then
we can finally get monster to a spot
where he's happy and healthy
all right buddy
come here fatty oh hi the most handsome
bird in all the land I would Fluffy Bird
you're so cute mister
the founders got something for you here
take this one where's it going over here
yeah that's so good
um
so our male spiny iguana boss has not
been maintaining weight uh despite an
increase in his diet
um and so just getting a little
concerned about him so I'm gonna run him
up to the vets and we're gonna do work
up on them all right come here buddy
[Music]
I hope that this is if we find something
it's something treatable Cancer's in the
back of your mind especially on this
case when you have an animal that's
losing weight but eating more and is
elderly cancer is going to be it it's in
the back of your head for sure
he's become one of our favorites and you
know he just doesn't give a crap about
anything like he lets you do whatever
you want and it's a big sweetheart hello
good morning God boss all right good
deal hey buddy
but I mean like my tips are starting to
come out now yeah it's really fun um
this is with eating he's eating every
single day
it's like nothing in there
I can actually see the bones in his tail
protruding because he's lost so much
muscle mass he's basically a skeleton
with the skin over it where you going
you saw the needle he's making a run for
it I'm pretty concerned for boss he
looks like he's in pretty rough
condition we don't have any idea yet
what's going on so we may find something
that's going to be very serious
that was a hard part buddy ready for him
yep
there's some nose up to that we'll see
if we can just cover them
we'll start with his CT because it's a
good way to get a good head to toe
evaluation of his organ systems we're
looking to see if there are any masses
any abnormalities does he have a tumor
somewhere
what's that
Moss our black iguana we took him up to
get ct'd and try to get some diagnosis
on them to try to figure out why he's
losing weight why he's looking so skinny
what's that
we could have kitty stones or bladder
stones I didn't feel anything back there
but when we look at the CT in the back
part of his abdomen near his pelvis
there are several large masses and it's
not clear to me whether these masses are
possibly stones in his bladder or
possibly outside his bladder pushing on
it
let's see if we can see this bladder the
next thing we're going to do with boss
is an ultrasound
so this is the wall of the bladder here
and around here I think of something in
the wall of the bladder which probably
is not good
so it looks like there's something
abnormal there he's going to send out
some tests and see if we can find out
what it is if it's a mask
if the radiologist agrees that there's a
master next thing would probably be
surgery okay so what the mess is and get
a piece of it all right um and we'll get
a blood work and Radiology report within
a couple days by mid-week and then we
can make a plan for him so sounds good
yeah well he's a good guy yeah thanks
for your cooperation sir I hope it's
nothing terrible
I mean the fact that you know Randy saw
something and that all signs are
pointing it could be cancer you know
he's such an innocent little animal you
don't want anything to happen to him I
mean boss is so old but as far as
iguanas go he's not nearly at the the
upper echelon there you know if it turns
out that this is manageable and
treatable I mean he could be around for
years and and that's what we want
cool thanks Randy well wait to hear from
you we'll be in touch
[Music]
hi Charles how are you good
I'm so excited our tunnel has arrived
and we are gonna put it in place at the
new Adventure Cove our new sea lion
habitat so this is a huge day the bummer
of the whole thing I'm just way too busy
to be there in person
it's lifting it oh hey
[Music]
hey oh my gosh they're putting
it yeah it's going down right now
Adventure Cove is gonna be our new sea
lion habitat this is going to be
bodega's home for good we also are going
to have Jack Cannon's animal encounters
Village and that's all of our ambassador
animals so we could be talking about sea
lions we could be talking about birds we
could be talking about reptiles all in
the same encounter it's going to be one
of the most amazing exhibits any Zoo has
ever had
foreign
I am so excited the guests will be able
to walk through this glass tunnel and
you'll be able to see the sea lions 360
degrees it's going to end up being one
of the best habitats we've ever built
here at the Columbus Zoo
here we go
please don't crack that thing
please tell me it fits
does it fit we'll find it we'll find out
here in a second whoa look at that you
know what surprisingly watching it on
video I felt like I was there
that guy better be careful okay
someone tells me they know what they're
doing
okay be careful
oh it looks like it's going down yep
oh my
God
it's in yeah
[Applause]
very well this is a huge moment for our
team
rock and roll time now that the tunnels
installed the crew down in Florida can
move forward and bring these animals
home the sooner the better
Cove is happening right around my big
birthday coming up
my 21st birthday is coming up later this
year and what better way to celebrate
than opening up this incredible habitat
I sure hope everyone's ready to party
oh Lord
foreign
[Music]
how are you good how are you doing how's
monster this morning uh it's a little
scared yeah it looks good hi buddy oh
nugget
we're taking monster in for another
dental exam today his face is still
swollen and I'm pretty worried because
we still haven't figured out exactly
what's going on I can't be there with
Munster today so Fred's gonna take him
out he's in good hands and Fred and Dr
Katie have told me they're going to keep
me really closely updated they know how
worried I am about Munster all right
Fred do you want to grab him up we're
going to give him a little injection and
then we'll get him down the rest of the
way with ISO
monsters had Dental issues for the last
couple months we've removed a bunch of
his teeth last time Munster was looked
at he had a swelling a CT was done to
try and figure out what was causing that
swelling we sent that out to our
radiologist for interpretation and it
came back as potentially a two-through
abscess what that means is there's a
little bit of a fragment of that canine
tooth that when it was pulled stayed in
and the tissue around it became kind of
inflamed and abscessed however it's not
a slam dunk absolutely this is what this
is things that pop to mind are infection
for other reasons or possibly a
cancerous process so we're going to
repeat some Imaging today and have the
Veterinary Dentist do an examination on
him I just need your booty okay
you got him all right enchiloris
I know okay you can go back in we'll let
him chill for a minute
this has been an ongoing thing for
Munster so Fred and Katrina and all of
his caretakers are expectedly concerned
Katrina couldn't be here today but she's
seen Munster through most of this ordeal
so I'm gonna make sure that I'm keeping
her closely updated along the way
hi people he says I have a little bit of
a grip
handsome how are you
if you want to help me get a little bit
of ISO on him I think he's not down
enough to intubate you people keep
holding my hands though
so when we're intubating an animal our
goal is to get control of the airway so
we're putting a tube into the trachea so
we can provide anesthetic gas and
control their breathing one of the
biggest challenges of working with
lorises especially in their mouth is how
small they are
they are truly tiny creatures 500 grams
that means that every part of them is
small including their Airway so when
we're trying to intubate them that makes
it a little bit trickier you're a good
boy
no one move no one breathes
thank you
good boy
that one move no one breathes
okay the stylet is in getting him
intubated is a huge sigh of release to
the fact that this was successful just
means that the rest of the procedure is
going to be a little less stressful
because we know we have that in place
you can disconnect that we're gonna
carry him separately come on handsome
man
protect the tube our goal is really to
figure out what that change in the CT
was so best case scenario there is a
routine two through we find it we take
it out it heals up beautifully worst
case scenario is that those bony changes
are something a little bit more
concerning like a cancerous process
it's like the tiniest human
okay good to go in all right
we get a new CT and things look very
similar to how they looked a month ago
which is why Dr burning is going to come
in to evaluate it
I have it lined up at the spot that this
is what I think they were looking at
last time
you know everything looks good through
here yeah
that looks beautiful I think we do have
some degree of periodontal disease and
you can see it's worse here so this is
bone loss yeah around these teeth
so I'm happy to see what we have going
on in here and maybe take a biopsy or
see what else is happening
there's nothing that is an obvious to
through which is what I kind of
suspected we would see
that doesn't necessarily look like a
straightforward tooth root it looks like
there may be some other changes either
from just chronic inflammation or other
things we may need to be worried about
so she's actually going to get in there
and take a biopsy of it
we'll send that stuff out and get an
answer as far as is this inflammatory
right is this some type of infection or
you know see see what we have going on
and then we'll have an idea of if we
need to do anything else
I believe that I am finished
[Music]
see the scariest thing that it could be
I think best case scenario is that by
scraping it out and doing a long course
of antibiotics we may actually get
resolution at least we're heading in the
right direction of getting an answer
there we go Guys open perfect
all right she's good to go all right
thanks for bringing him up Fred okay no
problem thank you yeah
foreign
[Music]
Randy what's up man got some of the
results back on Boss okay we are trying
to figure out why boss is losing weight
why is he looking so skinny we took him
up to get CT there was something that
looked like it could be a mass around
the bladder he is really old so we are
concerned what looked like a mess to me
he said it's just because boss is so
thin that's his pelvis pushing up on his
organ so uh okay that's why I send
things to a radiologist I'm not a
specialist I thought there was a mess
there he said no that's just normal
the fact that it isn't something I mean
it is relief it's great if it was cancer
something it probably would not have
turned out very well given his age so
we're back to having the thin iguana
nothing specific telling us what's wrong
unfortunately I can relate to that as
you get older you start to slow down
systems don't work as well as I used to
so that may just be where he is so okay
he actually did gain a little weight
um I actually think he's improved a
little bit but I'll wait and see what
you think he's starting to show some of
those age-related things that that
happens to to everyone it's coming for
all of us let's start feeding them every
day making sure he's getting a lot of
extra treats uh it kind of gets more
fattening to them it's more calories but
other than that I mean seems to be okay
we're gonna take another blood sample
make sure everything's back to normal
based on his uh physical exam and his
condition the results of his blood work
we're confident he'll make a complete
recovery
[Music]
all right thank you buddy
so we'll get the results back in a
couple days see if it tells us anything
but at this point I think we're going to
take it as a success all right man
back to the ladies
and boss is such a unique animal for his
species
we love him I mean for an iguana he's so
friendly I love him to death down here
so it's a giant relief
ready to go to Columbus yeah me too I am
so excited our sea lions traveled from
Florida last month now the animals are
settled here at the Columbus Zoo
for someone dumb
oh and he's got such great breath to get
Bodega back here I wanted him to land at
this incredible habitat he start gold
coming to the Columbus Zoo
[Laughter]
maybe he doesn't want laser therapy
[Music]
bodega's getting a laser treatment today
we noticed a while ago that he had some
paralysis and went to his uh back
flippers they say it's not uncommon for
these older big males so we do cold
laser therapy that helps Mobility for
him we're going to do whatever we can to
make the rest of his life the best it
can possibly be so that's what we're
going to be doing today
down
good boy that's a good boy you're good
he doesn't always want to cooperate I
think the pool is rating higher than
lazy therapy oh
[Music]
I'm ready he's not he's getting ready to
go
foreign
really well we did it perfect
[Laughter]
[Music]
so we tried to do bodega's laser but
he's not really focused he decides so we
don't will not force him to do it
it's a cooperation in between the
trainer and the animal so that's fine
gonna force him to do anything he
doesn't want to do
good boy he does look good though
doesn't he yeah
before we started the therapy he could
hardly use either one of his back
flippers he had no mobility in it
whatsoever by doing the cold laser
therapy it's successful it's working
pry it down down right good boy
you're good
it's increasing the blood flow to see
all these movements right now
can I do it yeah
always go down never in the eye or you
can kill someone like that
somebody with it
good
so he's using a little bit more to move
show it off
look at that
that's good movement that's awesome it's
really cool to see him starting to get
more and more Mobility you can even see
him tap when we ask him to tap you can
see the flipper move that makes me happy
spin
look at you
but Jake has been through a lot you know
being a 24 year old sea lion if he were
in the wild he probably would not still
be alive in fact I'm sure he wouldn't be
to see him here at the Columbus Zoo is
worth it all
there he goes
we're finally ready to open Adventure
Cove it's just so exciting we're so
close after so much work let's go
[Music]
thank you
hello just want to let you know a busy
day ahead of us we've got a gorilla exam
and some Winery checks and some ostrich
blood samples you know a lot going on
that's an understatement not only are we
incredibly busy but we're also in the
middle of a global pandemic
hi
is that you
[Music]
um
is that you yeah look at you
[Music]
should I put you on
that's so creepy
what it's ridiculous
covert's definitely challenged us in
many different ways it's been stressful
it's been scary
um so it's always nice to have a good
laugh and literally it looked like a
crazy person
do I look like me
what are those
[Music]
are the animal programs
go ahead Suzy
hey guys I need everybody to report to
the theater at Independence and AED and
I need all kind of bad staff please
thank you
tomorrow is the big day for us we are
opening Adventure codes
you know it's been a lot working through
this pandemic
trying to open an exhibit but we're
going to make it work you've seen we
made Provisions in there to keep the
public safe that's the key no matter
what I'm going to be smiling under this
mask I know you can't see it but it's
just going to be one big smile
Susie Susie Susie Susie
our sea lion or pinniped team has been
dependent on each other for everything
their social life their work life their
family life they truly are like a family
tomorrow is a very big day for all of us
and it has been an amazing journey
it's been a challenging Journey none of
us would have seen this coming that we'd
be opening up this incredible habitat
during a pandemic
and I believe this habitat is going to
help this Zoo get through this I am so
proud of each and every one of you so
tomorrow let's open these Gates let's
let the guests in
[Applause]
today's our big day we are opening
Adventure Cove
I am excited for the guests to get to
see these magnificent animals the sea
lions
the cheetahs
the two cans and The Battered foxes
there's so much in this exhibit
this has been years in the making
and it started with one sea lion
named Bodega I would have done all of
this just for him he's here to stay and
the fact that he gets the most
incredible sea lion exhibit in the world
it just melts my heart
here we go we're open
[Music]
I'm so excited I wish I could be here
all day
there we go
[Music]
this tunnel is the only one of its kind
there's no tunnel in the world where sea
lions can go beneath you or above you
there they go there they go
oh I love that
I see happy people you know getting to
see these sea lions swimming over them
and swimming under them and right in
front of them
you guys are getting a good show
it's a big big day for the zoo today we
are opening Adventure Cove but we have
something bigger to celebrate it's
Susie's birthday and I'm really excited
about that have a good surprise for her
today and I think she gonna love it
foreign
[Music]
hey Katie hey Katrina I just wanted to
share some pretty amazing news I just
got Monster's results back and it turns
out that that area that we biopsyched
back as just reactive tissues no cancer
which is fantastic this is the best case
scenario by far that's great news he
doesn't have cancer this is the best
thing we could have hoped for so I'm so
excited
so overall I think when we cure it at
the bone tissue out to get the biopsy
that's exactly what we needed to do
because it helped remove any of that
infected or reactive tissue that was
potentially still in there so we've got
all of that out but I would expect him
to have no issues from this moving on
and I think we just monitor him really
closely make sure he's eating well do
his routine annual checks but I think in
the clear right now as far as this issue
is concerned so I'm really excited that
this is the news I get to deliver to you
today and let me know if you have any
questions thanks Katrina have a great
rest of your day bye
I love when we get to have those moments
with the curators where we share good
news instead of bad news and for Monster
this is definitely the best news that we
could have hoped for
she's super excited about monsters news
it's been a recurring issue over and
over and I'm glad we finally figured out
what was causing it give him a little
relief and hopefully
um he lives his best life from here on
out
many more years to come with Munster and
we're super excited for that news
[Music]
okay
that I this is like the equivalent of
those fancy little flowers they put on
top boom Oh
now we're talking two dates are very
exciting day because it's banana two
years old birthday
[Music]
and banana is our first step so it's
special anymore for us and we want to
celebrate his birthday
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
but it's not only the Banana's birthday
it's also Susie's birthday
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday to you well I come down
for bananas birthday surprise and the
surprise wasn't just for banana it was
for me
[Music]
it's your birthday thank you
banana was my first sea lion pup born he
was born when we were down at the
holding facility in Florida are these
two yeah and I'm 39. wow
this is a big birthday for me a huge
birthday for me
why do you do this silly boy because you
are special from you guys are so special
happy birthday
[Music]
dad that doesn't happen to you
this sea lion team we've been through a
lot together it's been a long process
building this exhibit which is so
exciting and it's been a lot of emotion
and here I am celebrating my birthday
with our first baby sea lion ever born
it was the greatest birthday present
ever I mean here I am tearing up again I
don't tear up what's going on with me 60
more years let's do it my craziness is
gonna keep you all young you know it was
such a wonderful gesture it brought me
to tears but now everybody needs to get
back to work ends over now it's work
time
[Music]